ein kombi die treppe kommen lassen
los geht's und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge minecraft legend
wahrscheinlich einer der letzten folgen
dem wir haben uns verabredet zu dem fall
das wird jetzt gleich einfalt geben
gegen anymore entgegen ist amor und ich
gegen tom gegen lissabon gegen logo tom
gegen mich und logen oder wir beide im
team gegen andere wird sich zeigen so
wie es jetzt anbietet und es kann
losgehen von meiner seite aus ja ok frau
giftig noch ich hab alles alles hier in
der kiste war das tagebuch mit den waren
wir das tagebuch mit in den tod nehmen
in denen in den tod
oder weil man ziehen lassen quasi so als
schatz sitzt eine entscheidung ich hab's
dir eigentlich gemacht weil ich jetzt
dachte ja ich mache jetzt nur noch eins
gegen eins du bist auch schöne kombis
oder schwerter haben wir die ja es läuft
haben wir äpfel streams völlig ja er
drei spiele kommen noch ich hab mir
schon bogen gemacht da sind noch ein
bisschen pvp gegen dort oben sind auch
fehden drin haben wir wirklich keine
äpfel dass wir jetzt zu gehen ja ich
habe mir ein feuerzeug und tnt habe ich
auch mitgenommen
drei schräg und dann also wir machen
zwei gegen zwei
okay zwei gewährtes zwei machen dann ist
die also nicht okay dann machen wir das
so dann mache ich die angel
du musst du nur so schräg legen dann
zwei nach unten
okay da ist da war ich kann mir auch
noch eine machen wenn wir noch ein
bisschen holz haben da ist die an wenn
wir dann wenn wir dann tot sind laufen
wir noch zu allerdings ist und versuchen
dann noch was zu machen zu unserer
ersatz kister
wir sind hier wir sind die eigentliche
kunst so standardmäßig haben sie
geschrieben also sie haben jetzt nicht
die die heiltränke oder aber haben die
ihre ganzen schwert und rüstung ja
sicherlich werden sie da was haben
guck mal wir haben mit er mit ein
bisschen zeug was wir haben wir schon
gut was ausrichten
er wird elf weile feuerzeug drum und
dran noch ein verizon schwert
hinterlassen jahre vor meine ich alle ok
marco kurz crew in schotten auf zwei
oder vier f2p wall street alles gut dann
ja mama jetzt auf das man nämlich so
dass legend im jetzt zum ende finden
muss und logo es für nötig erachte das
ist genau jetzt machen und wollte schon
alleine gegen kämpfen und hab ich gesagt
nee da mache ich mich jetzt hier hast du
auch nicht bezahlt habe ich wenn ich
beim eine treppe aber so geht glaube ich
schneller schreibt binz braun
naja ich bin ja gerade das ist merkt man
herz und ausgeglichen das hätte gerne
etwas aus kann das wirklich so wird der
fall hier machen vom interesse aber ich
glaube so groß unterscheiden wenn es
sich weiter gucken wir haben es ist das
einzige was sie vielleicht noch haben
ist was enchanted ja und das macht mir
weiter unterschiede aus glauben
unterschätzt dass man liebe wir haben in
der ersten folge haben wir gekämpft und
sonst nie also jetzt
ich muss selbst schon sagen dass es mich
ich weiß schon ganz genau was nach der
aufnahme passiert hier gehe ich jetzt
weiter hoch
amerika ist das so eine echte unfassbar
tief meine fresse wir waren auch
betglocke das erde
hoffentlich ist es nicht nur eine erde
schicht sondern auch wirklich der
overground richtig ist ein bisschen
eisenach wie geht man jetzt vor wenn wir
zum beispiel sterben jetzt nur dass wir
das mal durchgesprochen haben ich bin
übrigens oben ich guck mal kurz wurde
diddy diddy wo kann man große map
anmachen auf day oder so eine y mak menü
kate waypoint logistics bei mir öffnet
nicht okay dass wir müssen also irgendwo
irgendeine vorstellung wo wir hinmüssen
ich glaub da vorne hinten oder vorne
ich wollte ganz gut aus sagt zwei sachen
sagen vor wieder in falten
erstmal ist wird eine fortsetzung im von
legend wo wir uns dann auch bisschen
mehr sagen wir mal so strukturen ist die
sache rein bringt ja dass er mich glaube
ich bisschen überfordert so dass er mal
das ganze strukturieren muss man sich
klarmachen muss das und ja dann
wir haben jetzt nämlich auch von 9 ist
das problem durch den strukturiert
fehler ist es wenn wir jetzt nicht
kämpfen dann also jetzt besser gesagt
nicht sterben oder jetzt noch leben dazu
kriegen und jetzt mehr folgen quasi
machen dann sind wir diese woche raus
wir haben das pensum nicht geschafft
dass die work wurde also müssen wir
genau die andere richtung
das heißt wir haben gut hast du noch gut
ja ich hab noch gut da dahinten hierher
wenn ich hier oben hier hier und zwar
ist es so wenn wir jetzt quasi die jetzt
nicht gemacht hätten
also nicht kämpfen sondern hätten wir
dass folgen kennen und diese woche nicht
erfüllt wären hätte machen können aber
ich finde auch müssen wieder falten ich
wollte eigentlich sowohl als gegen
andere teams machen aber logo
jetzt unbedingt gegen timo kämpfen ja
ich habe schon einen fehler aber mit ihr
könnt ihr sagen was ihr davon haltet
dass wir die entscheidung getroffen
haben in den kommentaren muss doch
irgendwo in die richtung quasi zu
unserem bohren geben den augen verloren
kranke besser meine grippeschutz impfung
bekommen um auf seinem berg leute der
nase putzen de waal raus haase die
sommer die call ist raus rücken
die käufer aus der pizza pudding
stanaway noch wir wollen das projekt
nicht abschließen sollte damit das ist
dann am ende irgendwie noch was wenn ich
zwar die sonst an folgen das ist das
woran wir jetzt raus geflogen hätten
also an am folgen pensum nein weil er
immer in mir stets update ich würde ihn
monster hoffentlich kann ich nicht das
kann ja wohl nicht sein
irgendwo noch ein brot also die
koordinaten sind ungefähr sind sie 300
180 dies könnten sie dem honig gern
haben
audi hat glaube ich nicht gedacht leider
hast hast du noch fehlen ja noch 18
das ist ein bogen machen bevor wir
loslegen monster eltern bei der s-bahn
bei 3 100 und 180 ungefähr da ich sehe
den spot schon ich sehe in bonn schon
ich bin schon in sichtweite von unserem
schönen toren ich werde auch mal hier
kurz etwa 281 ja da kommt meine
einstellung runter genommen
ich mache auch einiges mal zu was mich
jetzt irgendwie belästigen könnte was zu
unnötigen mini lex führt für mini lag
oder malta wie übertrieben schnell man
ohne frieden ist aber sicherlich hatte
heute ein 23 23 21 verstand her
davos ist ein bisschen kitsch und ich
bin vorne einen vergifteten vergiftete
die ich bin bei ausbauen will ist beim
spot oder sonst ein skelett in form bolt
nicht unter druck
ich weiß gar nicht wo du bist ja prax
vorn ich bin im spa bank freuen wenn ich
beim spawn bin ich auch aus unserer
richtung wo wir gekommen sind vom sumpf
da unten da unten ich sehe ich ich selig
ist nicht mehr drin
dieses dieser poison effekt ist so
übertriebene dieser poison effekt ist so
lächerlich übertrieben was man auf
unsere seelen getourt sind das weißt du
noch unsere sicherung skills ist da
drüben auf der anderen seite unter dem
roten dogma ja mein letztes food hat
sich hip hop oder popmusik
das angeln hätte ist kein essen jedes
letzte essen habe ich jetzt gerade
aufgebraucht mehr her zu kommen zu dir
schnell große rote pilze
das kann es doch nicht sein
da ist ein buch ist ein skelett mit
power bogen
ich kann die kläger ist man nur zach
dürfen wir dürfen sie ja nicht ach so ja
ich hörte man jedoch das skelett des
bogen getroffen erzählte nicht packe ich
habe mich ich kann es jetzt auch in
goldaktien kräften handkraft uns mal in
gold ab dann morning goldfolie die er
wirklich wirklich nix
captain sawa den könig an pflanzen aber
das reicht nicht
doch zombie vielleicht jetzt noch zombie
fleisch von dem zombies hast du denn da
kommt mit zombie village oh ja doch noch
zum flush draw sich regeneriert ich bin
jetzt wieder voll
ich darf jetzt halt nicht bewegen wegen
hunger effekt geben wie bitte kann ich
kann mich nicht bewegen wegen dem hong
kong effekt ja ich gratuliere ich habe
ein halbes jahr zeit und liebe es zu
essen
ja weil sie vorher schon rum standen als
du noch nicht bereit was okay jetzt bin
auch vergiftet ich lag aber immer noch
nicht hier ist noch einer den anderen
wieder fliegt natürlich so weit aus
wasser raus okay er hat nichts gedruckt
oder lasse mir das ding gedruckt ja ich
hab dir das gedruckt das liegt da
irgendwo
wie kann mir gar den zombie reinalter
wie kapitza hölle wie zur hölle kam mir
gerade einen zombie rein frage ich mich
auch da waren stufen am rand ja ok als
sportchef nämlich wunderbar alter
jährlich reichsbund wird ja klar
sporn schob mich halt wenn ich vom
zombie getötet werde
meine wir stets ab toll mein name meine
grafikkarte ist abgestürzt er fand jetzt
genommen
ich bin an unserer sicherungsseile jetzt
spinnen und käfer wunderbar an r
sicherungs gäste legten die ja schwert
und da liegt noch rüstung drin kanzler
herkommen überall essen haben mein
ganzes lied da noch der ganze darf ich
hab das wichtigste mitgenommen also die
rüstung und so weit hat der zombie
leider verloren sieben kinder hätten
etwas mit verloren der zombie damit wenn
du tot bist eine rüstung auf der cd an
sie das domizil eine rüstung an
es wird leute das kannst du nicht sein
warte ich komm gelaufen nein ich bin
gleich da helfe auch bei der natürlich
da tom ist hat auch die decken die ecke
nicht angeln alter meine tricks punkte
nicht das skelett ich hab's ja wir haben
nichts zu ändern ist es wirklich mal da
hin dass andere liegt in der
sicherungskasten ag auffällig vor hunger
unfassbar unfassbar solchen gründen
abgegeben 11 machen hatte und bald ich
komme auch ich hab ja da war so ein
missgeburten stufe hast du den golden
ablauf gesammelt hier ja den goldenen
apfel habe ich ja hast du das hat uns so
dass die erschwert es hierbei hinten bei
mir hier in der sicherungskopie ich von
der kann zumindest mal buden oder so
häufig fragen war jetzt das ist
unfassbar ist es sind solche miserable
zustände
das ist ja wie in einem dritte-welt-land
bei uns ja warum es nichts du damit ich
weniger verliere wahrscheinlich kinder
ich glaub mir jetzt
hast also das zufällig ich habe nur noch
den goldenen apfel entdecken geben
die schleppe das liegt an der küste
liegt rüstung und da an der
sicherungskasten die wolfslaker weiß
weiß ich jetzt nein unser kam
egal egal jetzt noch eine angel
dahinter ist name ach ja wohl kaum sich
ausgeloggt ausgeloggt der duke ist am
morro davon weiß rechtes total doppel
bitte wirklich das letzte essen was ich
habt uns vor hunger was ich habe man
essen willst du dich etwa hungern lassen
ja klasse gezielt darauf zu nehmen
willst du willst kannst du voran
etwas weiter ist die entmachtung kommt
zum spawn leute gar nicht mal rennen wie
kannst dich reden wir ja ihr habt mich
einfach auslassen zombie studios song
ich habe zombie vielleicht gefunden
diese aktion soll flash wir müssen uns
die gute taktik überlegen dass sie von
hinten aus seinem haus oder so anfallen
wo sind wir gut in survival game nix
wartet kommt oder schweigt für immer wir
sind low as [ __ ] dass die
zusammenfassung für dieses projekt low
as [ __ ] ja bla bla
das ist jetzt richtig pussy haft alter
wir haben einfach gar kein equipment ja
also ganz ehrlich diesen 1000 mal 1000
mal mehr als wir immer doch auch ohne
equipment ich mit ihr auf das nächste
wird besser darstellen und den upload
nicht über sterben aber dieses projekt
was ist los ein spaß nicht scheiß
projekt aber das müsste zu ende gebracht
werden
das muss zu einem ende gebaut werden
heute muss man terminiert werden
ja die kommen
die kommen zwei wir schon wieder ab was
ist los
ja nicht ich kann nichts dafür ist die
scheiße die ganze abstürzt alles fertig
sagt sie denn wieder ist die kleine
hatte laxey 22 stück habe ich noch eine
minute dann sind sie da
lass mal aus seiner position kämpfen wo
man richtig den vorteil hat dass man
schnell alles an pflanzen und ich habe
ja keine fotos machen
ja das sind aber nur 23 hier bin ich
offen döpfner pflanzen
ja ja der post aber das schaffen wenn
ich mir in der minute bekam jetzt
einfach rein und dreckig mit zombie
fleisch vor hier irgendwo hast ja ja
hier oben komme gehen so eine hausengel
sportsponsoring ja ja hier ist noch die
hälfte kommt weg weg läuft so viel
fleisch perfekte oder können wir noch
retten man da bist ja das ist ja ein
luxus meine lieben leute ok wo holen wir
jetzt die sollen brauchen wir zum sport
kommen dann machen wir auswendig und
dann gleich mal die einfache an
denn darauf und zwar zusammen auf ein ja
nicht ditto heißt es nicht geht sind die
city
ich sehe die wüste die aufbauarbeiten
jaja so lief es darf so den er nicht
toll wenn wir noch nicht mal fürs darf
weil ich lösche mal hier durch das
fenster entscheiden er hatte kein
oberteil an
doch hat er hatte hat er und mia schwert
enchanted jacke dagegen auf alle
gerichtetes fenster in eine komische
trap bekommen
die hälfte da reinkommen hereinlassen
demokratie hochkommen ja mach ich noch
jünger nämlich ziemlich schnell alles an
deine ist meist weiß kommt von unten
konnten von unten ja noch ein herz hirn
ein hurrikan in florida von newsweek und
das team zu respawn kees de vries
monkees telos schnell ja spornt mich
noch als spongebob mich noch wunderbare
hat es ist okay ich bin das netz leben
wieso bin ich jetzt rausgeflogen alter
das war unser letztes leben was wir
hatten
ok dann konnte doch kurz vor bin ich
rausgeflogen
ja wahrscheinlich wegen dem leben weil
du weil das leben alle war ich
fasziniert am steuer erwischt
wir haben damen sind noch gekriegt wo
ich weiß was ich weiß war auch richtig
gemacht ich hab mich jetzt raus weiß hat
mich raus ja weiß hat mich oder weiten
bogen reingehen und er hat mich ja bis
dahin ja das war das von microsoft
legend es wird eine fortsetzung geben
und da werden wir strukturierte dran
gehen
ich hoffe ihr versteht dass wir jetzt
ein strich drunter setzen wollten und
die sache erledigen wollten damit
schönen schnitt rausgeht die folge war
noch richtig lustig wir haben gezeigt
dass wir auch wirklich noch teams die
krass op sind trotzdem noch klappt ich
stell dir vor er hätte jetzt alleine
gegen uns gekämpft und weiß hinterher
gekommen hätten uns einfach das schwert
und alles ich hatte ja die börse an
die wehrten die hatte die fast geklappt
also ich war noch ganz zufrieden mit dem
endkampf platz mit anders ausgehen leute
wenn es euch gefallen hat lasst gerne
den daumen nach oben dafür die letzten
folge legend von uns und wir sehen uns
garantiert bei anderen videos wieder
macht's gut v3 und